This is Major
I'm On Site
I'm going in
You are the first of your kind
But your'e not invulnerable
Maybe next time you can design me better
Everyone around me, they feel connected to something
Connected to something I'm not
what are you?
You were dying, we saved you
and now we save others
I don't know who to trust
You trust me right?
I know I have a past
I'll find out who I was
Everything they told you was a lie
who are you?
They did not save your life, they stole it
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so Ghost In The
Shell dropped let's break it down.
Also let me know the first time you ever saw
Ghost In The Shell.
So most of you probably know at least a little
bit about the ghost in the Shell franchise
there are a couple of different films some
are remakes of the original 1995 film but
that film itself is an adaptation of Manga.
So if you're a big fan of manga your big fan
of anime I would recommend you just rewatch
the first film this live-action film is basically
that story so just as a general recommendation
if you're looking for the order to rewatch
the original anime before this movie comes
out you can either watch the animated TV series
or the movies so the movie order you should
watch is the ghost In The Shell 1995 film
then ghost In The Shell 2, Then the laughing
man movie then individual 11 and standalone
complex solid-state society and then the ghost
in the Shell new movie I would recommend you
just keep it simple.
They're all pretty fantastic, but the best
is that original 1995 felt that was the one
that blew my mind when I saw for the first
time but the watch order for the TV series
is standalone complex second gig and then
arise.
So there's plenty of ghost in the Shell out
there but some of it is a remake of previous
ghost in the Shell so that's why usually start
with the 1995, or at least start with the
manga if you really want to read the manga
the trailer pretty much explains the broad
strokes is basically this Westworld type story
you have this idea of evolving artificial
intelligence and how scary that can be you
see that she has this real brain, but the
fact that she has so many cybernetic parts
leaves her very open to cyber attacks like
a lot of 80s 90s computer technology based
stories, there's a lot of hacking that's going
on in the movie but you can kind of see how
like the different characters have various
levels of electronic prosthesis that is a
big thing in the film so like people have
a lot of robotic parts there are people who
are fully robots.
Some are mostly robot which is basically like
the Major character.
She with the exception of her brain is fully
cybernetic, but the cool thing here.
You may recognize this is that this is Euron
Greyjoy here from game of thrones playing
Batou so I thought that was kind of fun to
spotting him.
L lot of these iconic trailer moments are
moments from the original film, like the big
action set pieces were she basically takes
her clothes off and jumps off the building.
You can see that they kinda made this for
a broader audience.
It's a little more hardcore she's actually
fully nude in the animated movie when she
jumps off the building.
But then you have the service droid in the
harem the goes haywire that's right out of
the 1995 film the trailer jumps pretty quickly
into the idea that she is slowly starting
to experience something happening with her
brain.
That's the hacking element of the movie because
she's mostly cybernetic so any digital circuit
can be hacked so that she is open to the puppet
master who is this figure here for you to
be is like the person that speaking to her
about them stealing her body.
So without giving away spoilers about who
he is and how he evolved.
Just remember like Westworld, it's a story
about the evolution of artificial intelligence
like your baby basically like at the precipice
here in during the movie they address that.
And if you're wondering what the song is displaying
under this is a version of Depeche Mode enjoy
the silence which when you listen to the lyrics
does kinda play into the theme of her kind
of joining this giant digital consciousness.
So if you're wondering why they used it, the
song was also kind of written during the period
when the Manga was coming out like late 80s
early 90s.
So seems pretty appropriate that they would
attach to ghost In The Shell movie, but let
me know what you guys think I know a lot of
people be focusing on Scarlett Johansson as
the Major character because she basically
carries the film but there are other big characters
like the puppetmaster and Batou.
I'm really interested to see Euron Greyjoy
in this film, he's a really big character
in the original story.
so just to reiterate if you really want to
watch some ghost in the Shell I recommend
you just start with the 1995 film but let
me know what your favorite ghost in the Shell
is.
I haven't read the Manga in a long long time
but I usually do rewatch the film at least
once a year, just because it's so awesome
I remember encountering this film around the
same time, I saw Akira for the first time
just because they kinda come from the same
aesthetic and usually if you have a friend
that introduces you to anime and they give
you Akira, they also give you ghost in the
Shell just because they kinda go hand-in-hand
before you go for the more obscure stuff.
But just reminder the movie is coming out
March 31st, so it's not going to be out for
a little while.
So there will probably be a couple more trailers.
So it will be cool to see how close they stuck
to that original story but what's going to
happen later tonight is I'll post my walking
dead episode four video after it airs.
So be sure to subscribe to get that.
There will be new Marvel, I was originally
going to do Deadpool today but then this dropped.
So Walking Dead next, Deadpool on Monday got
a bunch of marvel and DC stuff happening in
the next couple weeks just because there is
so much TV and movie stuff happening.
Which you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my latest game of thrones season
7 video and you can click here for that Dave
Chapelle walking dead skit.
Thank you so much for watching!
Everybody high five and I'll see you tonight!